is a great danger to me here well they
say it's a great danger but I have to do
it I love the country there's nothing
more important than what I'm doing and
I'm the one that brought up the problem
of illegal immigration and it's a big
problem it's a huge problem you folks
know it better than anybody and you look
at the crowds outside we have big crowds
are all screaming in favor of Trump
everybody wants because they want the
problem fixed when I think Rick Perry
did a terrible job as the governor of
Texas where he the border security was
terrible now your new governor of Texas
I think is doing a great job have it
governor Abbott's doing a great job but
Rick Perry honestly I don't think even
understands what it means oh he's
following my late absolutely I mean
we're the ones that brought up the widow
wife you know I took a lot of heat the
first week and then the second week
everybody realized I was right they just
did a big poll in Nevada the state of
Nevada and I'm Way ahead and more
importantly as far as I'm concerned I'm
way way ahead with the Hispanics well
into the 30s which and I think second is
like 11 so I have a great relationship
over the years thousands and thousands
of Hispanics have worked for me and now
work for me and the relationship is very
good there is a huge problem with the
illegals coming through and in this
section it's a problem in some sections
it's a massive problem and you have to
do you have to create you have to make
the people to come in they have to be
legal where is it in favor of a law oh
yeah certain sections you have to have a
wall absolutely by the way the wall the
wall will save you a tremendous amount
of money but you absolutely there are
areas and you have to have the world